The joe rogan experience sands process.
Awkward moment ever is when they see like in Vegas,
about five dudes hanging out together and there's no girls near him.
And then they're getting a couple of drinks in them and they start sorta like
half dance and they can't like totally commit to dancing,
you know,
so like little go through like half the moves.
Like I'm not really an advocate of this music.
It doesn't make me move that much.
But you know,
I'll give a little move,
we'll get up a little move here and there,
you know,
but they can't like dance with each other.
They can only move just a minimal amount.
You can't get crazy
gyrating hips.
This is a,
you're not allowed to do that to dude's girls can get together and dance all
they want.
But with dudes you can only sort of half dance.
I said,
God,
just by myself.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Sometimes you should go out by yourself to clubs.
Um,
when I first moved to La I did,
but I would go on the dance floor by myself.
Oh my God,
there's something wrong with your brain.
You need to go to a doctor
first.
It's a little bad at first you didn't get to get the guys that are like,
look,
what's this guy doing?
You kind of do it,
but then you get the girls that come over to you because they liked the guy who,
who's then we've done a lot of work.
Yeah.
It's a little gutsy.
It was a very gutsy move.
Got You.
Moved.
Not,
not always worked.
How many times is it failed on you?
Oh,
I don't even know.
Probably more times than but that,
but it just takes that one time.
You know?
Just that one time.
Some dudes can take criticism and rejection rather.
Some dudes are fine with that.
I have a friend,
he would,
he would hit on every girl that he was an ugly guy.
It was.
I was fat,
but he didn't give a fuck.
He would swing.
He would swing at every pitch.
I know a couple of Evernote that way that I know that he's a comic.
I don't want to give him up on the air.
I've owned you.
Do you mind?
Either,
but you can't go to bars with that guy because it's too much to my,
and then those are always the guys who let people know you're a comic.
Like there's a whole bunch of comics that are that way.
So they go up to the boundary like,
Hey,
we're the comics had to chuckle,
hut.
And then the bonds are usually like,
I don't care
what you want,
free tickets or the want the girls to be impressed.
It's bad.
It's brutal when you were,
the dude will,
you know,
there's no way.
If you go somewhere and there's a chick that he's not going to hit on her and
it's not going to get annoying and it's not going to get embarrassing.
Yeah,
those guys are brutal.
Or you know,
it's like,
okay,
I can't hang out with you anymore because if I hang out with you and we go
somewhere,
you look and immediately just everything that moves the first fucking the
waitress comes over.
I think she's kind of,
Oh man,
look at that.
And just talking to him.
And then next thing you know all,
it's all about this fucking waitress and him getting this,
which was his number.
I'm like,
Whoa,
I can't,
you just have lunch,
fucking Weirdo.
And then they don't come to your table anymore cause they don't want to deal
with Ya.
And then,
yeah,
exactly.
And it,
cause it works every 30th time.
They fucking just want to put in those numbers,
man.
Yeah.
Those crazy dudes,
they just want to put in those numbers and if you're around them and be like,
oh great,
no,
that's a person.
Yeah,
it's fucking disastrous,
man.
It's a shitty feeling.
I would add,
well they either move,
when I was on by myself,
I would go up to girls and say,
my friends left me,
can I dance by you?
So I don't look like I'm dancing by myself.
Then you dance.
But here's,
here's the trick,
young guys,
here's the thing.
You have to commit to that and you don't talk to those girls.
You don't go,
can I Bebo and then,
hey,
what's up ladies?
Then you ignore them.
Ooh,
okay.
And then the cooler,
one of the group will then kind of come over and go,
you can then,
then they'll let you into the circle if you're not completely hideous in and
embarrassing them.
Key is,
is not to give him attention.
After you do that little move.
Wow,
and then now you're the hurt animal in the forest.
You're the bird with a broken wing and there'd be one nurturing girl in that
group that will bring you in.
I just go up to him and go,
Hey,
I'm a producer like her
moves.
Ladies.
I just want you to just stop and think about how fucking gross and Maryland have
you heard of Tang brothers?
I started,
I stopped for a second and think of how gross men are and how fucking,
how much effort you put into creating the perfect environment where they think
you're a nice guy or interesting or mysterious or cute or whatever the fuck
you're doing.
How much of most,
most guys,
every day focus is just to try to get girls to like him.
44 4% of the day.
Yeah.
That's Brian.
Brian gets off for Brian's like Brian has no loads left.
How much masturbation and girls he's got no loads left.
He's got no time for your bullshit.
Yeah,
white fucking around.
John,
why are you fucking around man?
So these girls get stupid with him.
Like I have no loads for you.
You're dancing plan.
Could you just need to hit out the fat?
You spend too much time with that dancing clan.
And what is your dancing plant,
Brian?
Just go up to and go,
hey
producer,
what do you produce here?
I'll put the girl,
I'll play the girl.
Ready?
Hi.
Uh,
so I'm a producer.
Oh Wow.
What do you do?
What do you produce?
Wait tables right now.
Pretty sure it's going to work.
Or do we say,
hey,
you got to,
you got Facebook.
What do you produce?
Here's my Facebook.
All right,
I'll do it here.
Here.
Let me type it in for you.
Oh,
what's your,
what's your passcode?
I'm not gonna remember this.
Okay.
Can you say that louder?
All right,
cool.
All right.
See,
I'm just gonna turn on your mobile.
Me Right here and location services.
All right,
cool.
Cool.
And here.
All right,
cool.
You there?
There's my Facebook.
Whoa.
Stunna dumped check.
Sure.
Like what the fuck does magic
you remember that girl used to date a long time ago?
Jessica?
The first thing I said to her,
she was playing with her iPod and we're all out to dinner.
And I go,
Hey,
let me or refragmented your iPod for you.
She goes,
what is it running slow?
And I'm like,
yeah,
let me re fragment for you.
And I took it a night,
did all this stuff,
and I'm like,
there,
it should be running a lot faster now.
And she goes,
wow.
I didn't even know you could do that.
What's your name?
That's how we,
so what did you actually do?
You did nothing.
I just kind of,
I forget what it was.
Shitty taste in music.
She has been smothered or all these Bob Seger songs,
rock
got from that commercial,
ever danced to the song on the commercial.
That's where I know it from.